[Music]
what do i know that you need so bad
that's why you're here to find out
[Music]
you're not crazy you never have been
do you find yourself drawn to places
you've never been
the visions you've had your entire life
aren't hallucinations
they're memories they're talking about
reincarnation the legend never die
we call ourselves the infinite we
remember skills from all our past lives
[Music]
it takes 10 000 hours to master
how could you be after a million hours
pretty damn good
what do i know that you need so bad
that's why you're here to find out
we have fought one another for centuries
but you can't stop what's coming the end
of all things
is he blocked well well well we're gonna
have to reset your memory
you gonna drown me i gotta think about
drowning which is i don't like it
you know what man i like you this time
around shut up and turn it on
[Music]
there's still time time
no more time
leap of faith time did you see that
the legend never dies
okay none of you are my child has anyone
seen murray huh
we are fighting a war 30 years in the
future
is a joke our enemy is not human
we need you to fight you got drafted
i will be back why is this happening
what about the teachers deferment
and the veterans deferment if i don't go
they're going to draft you in my place
but if something does happen to me you
and miri will be taken care of
if something happens to you dan seventy
percent of draftees do not return
sometimes a man does what's best for his
family not himself
move your shirt please what's this for
you just test
oh a seat belt was it a driving test no
you don't have jokes in the future
this device facilitates your jump to and
from the future war
one minute to jump i'll hear everybody
take that
you just look around like that are you
so calm long story yeah
it's military yeah kind of a short story
i guess
three two one
in 11 months time all human beings in
the future will be wiped from the face
of the earth
unless you help us
i was trying to save my daughter if i
got to save the world to save her then
i'm going to do it
this is the end the human species will
disappear from the face of the earth
we are literally living on borrow time
there's still a chance that we can stop
this wolf remember happening
so we gotta fight
well it's nice knowing you
[Music]
so
[Music]
what i'm about to show you
has only been known to a handful of
people
even less have ever seen this
this is project rainfall
well i don't prepare for war right is
their technology integrated with ours
it's a beautiful thing
i've hidden from this war long enough
i'm gonna make sure you complete your
mission
you are cannot surrounded
oh that's not good
here we go
i'm with you is not all the times that
we fall but that we rise again
every single time
what else you got
go back
call him as you see him
you're going on a journey a journey
through memory
all you have to do is follow my voice
[Music]
we're closed i know i'm sorry it's late
we have time for one more job
when the waters began to rise and war
broke out
[Music]
nostalgia became a way of life
there wasn't a lot to look forward to
so people began looking back
nothing is more addictive than the past
no no no no no put me back
put me back
she has moved on and you should people
don't just
vanish to find where she'd gone i had to
know where she'd been
with me
you think you are necessary
where is he where is he
[Music]
bribery murder people love their secrets
don't go down this path stay here in
this life
i've turned the blind eye to plane i
have to do this
that machine of yours how close can you
get
before the illusion's broken
you're going on a journey all you have
to do is follow my voice
[Music]
why does this
[Music]
is
[Music]
listening
we have watched
unguided we have helped them
progress
[Music]
and seen them accomplish
wonders
throughout the years we have never
interfered
until now
good
[Applause]
[Music]
so now that captain rogers and iron man
are both gone who do you think's gonna
lead the avengers
i could lead them
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dreamed them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
[Applause]
pain
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
[Applause]
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Applause]
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what does kepler teach us louise
we will not think about ourselves
we will not let our emotions guideless
we do this for the many
she was called mother earth
we plundered everything she offered
all reproductive efforts failed for both
men and women
they want to prove that we can procreate
here
survivors i saw a child
without transmission none of this even
matters
why are you following me i want to help
you
[Music]
we waited so long i'm so pleased that
you're here with us now
it's imperative now that we bring our
people
[Music]
are they coming
[Music]
the human race doesn't need us to
survive
are you still with us blake
there's so many none of us should have
come back
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank everybody
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a cold fish there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that
put these on okay fine oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy there is no easy way to
say this
this world it's a video game
the guy responsible for this world was
going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now if that's not real
i don't know what it is i know this
world is just a game for this place
these people that's all i have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy next
guy i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity if you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that
that actually hurt my hand we could save
our world
but we have to fight together
[Applause]
i can't die
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
[Music]
my grandfather died
my mom says we're just here to pick
through the rob love's life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
uh
[Applause]
i say either just say either i say
neither
can i say neither either
neither neither let's call the whole
thing off
excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
he says hi one is the loneliest number
that you'll ever
do i mean thinking of much
you and i are the same
[Music]
every decision we ever make
who do we leave behind and how
do we leave them waiting
in the darkness the rescuer who never
comes
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
soon come chaos
chaos soon
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you're gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no
no you cannot eat mrs chen what nothing
every warrior has the
i'm beginning a new level for 600 years
our ninja had brought peace
i need warriors like you join us
what do i have to do
the journey from here
is yours to decide
but that is just the beginning i'm on a
new level
[Music]
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our role
it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
bring her home
[Music]
[Music]
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you're a gift you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
is an overpowering urge to consume blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up
i gave you 10 years to live your life
now you see me rise and where did that
get you
you walked in my shadow
i trained
so the you dangerous people in the world
couldn't kill you
son it's time for you to take your place
by my side
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can't out run
who are you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay hold on everybody
we make a good team
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people team two is clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you we're here to save you you were
gonna save
me it was a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do
it that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn
bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your
this is the skull suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail a mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth harley although that
isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell am i
supposed to know you're the leader
you're supposed to be decisive and i've
decided that you should eat a big bag of
dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem why
would someone put
penises all over the beans that's why
mad men do what they do
it's just suicide well that's kind of
our thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
no kids allowed on the beach
oh no we never leave each other nothing
separates us
are we there yet you said five minutes
technically it's been more than five
minutes
let's just all start slowing down
[Music]
wow you believe i found this online i
guess it's not that secret of beast
who would leave this from the hotel
they're so rusted
what's happening found stuff from the
hotel in the sand
[Music]
ready
what happened to her mom i don't know
what happened to her body has decomposed
how quickly can that happen seven years
but she just died
wait where are the kids cara come here
hey have you seen my children mom i'm
i'm right here
why are you looking at me like that
what's happening to us
my daughter just turned six two weeks
ago
whatever's happening to us is happening
very fast you have wrinkles
there's something wrong with this beach
what's
we have to get off happening beach
people are blacking out going this way
if she makes it to the ledge she might
have a chance why she's stopping
what's she stopping can i wake up wake
up
they have to know what this place does i
don't know you're a liar look
what is that a message we never leave
each other nothing separates us
we're connected to something bigger
oh no we're here for a reason
[Music]
you